[Aplausos]
[Música]
es la española una aceituna como ninguna
está rellena de rick anchoa
quien utiliza la masilla el cocinero
eficiente la mamá inteligente y muy
gustosamente gente exigente
o suenan
me alegro ha quedado aún en la memoria
los de marketing que hacemos pues como
ha dicho david pues de intentar vender
las marcas que no los que nos dan no
pero siempre tenemos que responder a
cuando estamos trabajando siempre es
tenemos que responder a los grandes
preguntas
que estamos vendiendo ya quien se lo
estamos vendiendo
que estamos vendiendo siempre estamos
viendo un primero lo mismo marcas
y esas marcas son nombres palabras y son
palabras e imágenes y valores
y aquí eso lo estamos vendiendo pues a
personas es que al final el mercado está
hecho de personas y esas personas son
criaturas son criaturas que tienen esa
esa consciencia de existencia y eso es
algo bonito nos diferencia parece ser el
resto de las criaturas de la creación de
que los humanos tenemos esa consciencia
de nuestra existencia
y nosotros tenemos que trabajar con esas
personitas metiéndoles dentro de la
cabecita
un archivo mental de una marca
y eso no tiene que ser fácil tiene que
ser un poquito complicado
y como es complicado pues recurrimos a
otras disciplinas de gente que sabe que
científicos disciplinas como la
psicología la neurociencia la sociología
y así intentamos segmentar ese mercado
amplio que siempre tenemos y
concentrarlo un poquito más para que el
mensaje vaya lo más directo posible
es decir que trabajamos con marcas pero
que queremos meter en la cabecita de las
personas y para ello lo que hacemos es
segmentar y en esa segmentación las
modernas psico sociodemografía ha
etiquetado a las personas de una manera
muy muy simpática
no nos ha dicho qué
hay una generación silenciosa que es la
que vivió en guerras demasiadas guerras
y esa canción silenciosa metió la pata
en una cosita y es que no transmitió a
las siguientes generaciones lo grave que
son las guerras se lo callaron se la
incidencia
pero en cambio hiciera una cosa
divertida quiera hacer criaturas hacer
criaturas más divertidas en este mundo y
esto lo hicieron muchas muchas y
entonces salimos la generación siguiente
los del baby boom los los boomers que
eso nos llama bueno esa generación fue
una generación que tenía cierta ambición
pero era una ambición de deseo de ser no
del deseo de tener por eso pues salió
este mundo hippie y todo esto
y de esa generación ya vino la siguiente
que es una generación x x pero que es by
es guay esa generación es muy exitosa
ella muy exitosa
fijaros que pasamos de una tele en
blanco y negro los de antes los del
boomers a un mundo en color y con un
walkman incluso que nos permite ir por
la calle en conectados
estudiando y aprendiendo etcétera
etcétera no
fijaros como miniaturista todo
y esta generación dio paso a la
siguiente que
es la famosísima cuando ahora se nos
diferencia a los mayores con los jóvenes
siempre se habla de la generación y que
son los millennials los famosos
millennials y esa generación pues se le
atribuye que está un poco frustrada
cuando en realidad no tendría por qué
porque el web nació con ellos es decir
la web nació con ellos el web también
también cuando digo la web me refiero a
la red
y pero cambiamos porque están frustrados
pues quizá porque son muy yo yo yo yo mi
me conmigo y entonces ese egoísmo aísla
israel y el aislamiento frustra pero
vamos a la que ahora a la de ahora a la
que yo tengo en clase ahora
y es la generación z que es una
generación irreverente pero que es
normal que sean irreverente es que es lo
que toca a la edad que tienen ahora es
que nos pensamos que solamente son
jóvenes los de ahora y los que ya
estuvimos antes también fuimos jóvenes
irreverentes y así es el ciclo de la
vida y hay que dejar que fluya porque la
vida tiene el deseo de sí misma de
crecer y de evolucionar y tenemos que
compartirlo y en ese compartir pues
tenemos que entendernos un poquito todo
eso tenemos que ser conscientes de que
estamos regidos por algo dice la segunda
ley de la espiritualidad india que lo
que sucede es porque tenía que haber
sucedido y tenía que haber sucedido que
nos juntáramos los que nos hemos juntado
que la tecnología fuera como va que la
guerra ocurrirá cuando ocurrió que no
vuelva a ocurrir y que habían elecciones
de nuevo de españa sea lo que suceda
tenía que haber sucedido para que no lo
sabemos pero lo que hay
y bueno en esa en esa dirección yo tengo
la suerte de por la edad que tengo de
haber tenido en clase
todas estas generaciones estoy dando
clases del 93 entonces han pasado todos
con mi por mí y no veo tantas
diferencias generacionales ya sé que
ahora se habla de brecha de contienda
generacional pero yo no veo tantas
diferencias y no tantas diferencias
porque en el fondo en el fondo lo que
tenemos todos somos muy parecidos nos
dicen los que saben de estas cosas que
tenemos ahí dentro 86 mil millones de
neuronas interconectadas unas cuando una
en ellas continuamente y claro lo que
ocurre es que estas esas conexiones las
tienen un caminito que le vamos haciendo
nosotros no van ellas no hacen lo que
les da la gana ellas cumplen su papel y
les importa un pepino todo porque en su
móvil conexiones electro físico-químicas
pero por qué porque hacen el papel que
cada una de una manera porque unos
actúan de manera actúan de otra pues
porque todos tenemos eso que se llama
pensamiento único que es aquel que voy a
leer los los voy a leerlo porque si lo
digo mal quedará fatal hoy es líder eso
del pensamiento único es de ignacio
ramonet que es un escritor y periodista
y filósofo famoso un importante que vive
en francia pero es español y nos dice
que el pensamiento único es una especie
de doctrina viscosa que insensiblemente
envuelve cualquier razonamiento rebelde
lo inhibe lo perturba lo paraliza y
acaba por algo
es decir es todo lo que no nos conviene
porque en realidad lo que nos conviene
es el pensamiento crítico el pensamiento
que cada uno le conviene desarrollar en
función de su vida su evolución sus
experiencias sus conocimientos sus
relaciones etcétera etcétera
y ahí desarrolla un criterio propio y
con ese criterio guía su vida por donde
le interesa guiarla por lo tanto frente
a ese pensamiento único que es lineal y
que al final de ese pensamiento único
hay esa zanahoria que obviamente nos
dicen que es buena porque es muy buenas
fotos así fuera son buenísimas pero es
el regalo es el premio que siempre se da
en el pensamiento único tú hace esto
esto es lo que al final tendrás ese
premio
y si resulta que el premio me lo puedo
dar yo y lo hacen ahora y me lo puedo
dar yo y hago lo que yo creo que debo
hacer y sigo siendo una persona que va
creciendo y evolucionando como creo que
nos corresponde a todos crecer y
evolucionar en este mundo
pues en esa línea
y yo trabajo las palabras porque
debemos saber que el mundo no marcas
para la versión importante está viendo
yo he querido aplicar estas palabras al
mundo de la persona
y soy consciente que hay dos palabras
como muy fundamentales dos verbos que
son esenciales para hablar de la persona
porque si no estamos aquí no podemos ser
persona
tenemos que estar aquí tenemos que
llegar y ya sabemos cómo se llega
hacemos cosas divertidas dos personitas
y estas cosas hacen una criatura y ella
y se llega y ya estábamos ya estábamos y
a partir de que estamos podemos ser pero
sí cuando estamos no somos
mal también cuidados
entonces esto ya nos lo decían los
clásicos griegos que el ser humano es un
cuerpo es mente y es alma
y ahora modernamente tampoco tan
modernamente porque ya este nos lo dijo
la energía es como muy necesaria y ahora
los cuánticos ya la releche sin energía
no hay cuántica no
y observación claro
en esa línea yo creo que es muy
importante que cuando una persona se
estudia a sí misma tenga muy claro cuál
es su espacio y cuál es su tiempo
en la vida de todos pasamos varios
espacios y varios cientos y todos
tenemos que ser conscientes en esa
evolución vital de cada uno de cuál es
su momento
y en ese momento qué orden está poniendo
él a su vida
algunos ponen desorden pero bueno y qué
ritmo
y los ritmos quizás son excesivamente
rápidos en estos momentos por lo tanto
probablemente convenga para usarlos un
poquito pero bueno eso va con la edad y
ya llegará el momento yo solo quiero
haceros unas pequeñas reflexiones sobre
palabras porque he venido hablar de
sobre palabras
y lo que me gustaría es que vosotros
pensarán las palabras
porque es importante pensar
y sobre todo pensar palabras tan clave
para la vida de las personas que pensar
en la palabra familia
podríamos estar aquí sin una familia
podríamos vivir sin una familia
podrías no podríamos hasta morir sin una
familia qué ocurre cuando nos vamos que
ocurre cuando llegamos esto todo está en
la familia luego quizá sea un elemento a
priorizar veríamos en nuestras vidas
esta es una decisión vuestra es decir
aquí tenéis cuatro factores cuatro
palabras cuatro espacios en los que vos
usted es que priorizar cuál es mi mi
espacio principal es la familia son las
amistades es la sociedad es el
patrimonio es una decisión nuestra
y es muy importante que lo tengamos
claro seguro que vamos cambiando lo
largo de la vida en prioridades pero es
importante que no nos dejemos ninguna
fuera porque aunque sea un poquito algo
para que cuidarla para luego cuando
quieres retomar la tenerla simplemente
y es que hemos agregado hemos agregado
genética sí pero también hemos heredado
cultura de las familias claro de los
padres por supuesto pero de la sociedad
también y de los amigos y del patrimonio
también o sea la suerte
en que nos estamos entrenando en que
estamos entrenando en nuestras neuronas
para [ __ ] el caminito que tienen que
[ __ ] que nos que queremos que cojan lo
que nos dicen que queremos que [ __ ]
sino que queremos nosotros que coja
como estamos aprendiendo a manejarnos en
nuestra vida con nuestras neuronas con
nuestro cuerpo por nuestra mente con
nuestra alma como estamos aprendiendo
y esos son elecciones siempre estamos
eligiendo si hacemos otras cosas para
las personas la parte de elegir no estoy
hablando de las elecciones de mañana de
cuidado
y en ese proceso de elegir siempre
siempre siempre todas las personas
estamos permanentemente manejando nos
entre razón y emoción siempre no tomamos
ninguna decisión que no sea mezcla de
razón y de emoción y en esa mezcla gana
la emoción porque la emoción es la que
elige y la razón es la que justifica
y como lo hacemos por en función de lo
que miramos lo que escuchamos las
percepciones que tenemos del mundo que
cambian por completo porque cada uno ve
lo que quiere ver escucha lo que quiere
escuchar y percibe lo que quiere
percibir y por eso delante de la misma
circunstancia somos muy distintos
pero lo importante es lo que hacemos
porque no se nos va a valorar ni por lo
que mires ni por lo que dejas de mirar
ni por lo que piensen ni por lo que
sientes se nos va a volar siempre por lo
que hacemos por lo tanto las acciones
son como muy fundamentales como
priorizamos esto en nuestras vidas todos
estos factores que importante le damos
uno importante le damos a otros
probablemente el más importante de todos
sea el amor
hay algo más importante que el amor pero
no un amor excluyente en que solo es el
amor del que tengo al lado sino un amor
amplio generoso que llegue todo el mundo
y en ese amor
desarrollar al máximo la inteligencia la
comprensión el respeto a todos en esa
inteligencia no olvidemos que cada uno
tiene la suya en mayor o menor prioridad
todos las tenemos todos pero cada uno
tiene más talento en una que otra por lo
tanto respetemos esas inteligencias que
significan todo es lo mismo elegir entre
y ayudemos a cada uno inter lakers e
inteligencia elegir entre ayudemos a
cada uno en que elija lo que quiera
elegir en función de su pensamos de
pensar de ser y de sentir
y en ese sentido el trabajo que se un
trabajo que nos satisfaga que nos viene
y por supuesto no olvidemos manos alguna
cervecita de vez en cuando porque si no
pasamos los días pensando y no estamos
nada de vez en cuando por no vamos no
vamos bien el ocio es importante darle
dos patas al valor es importante es
decir la mezcla de todo no pongamos todo
esto en una rueda de cita como la que yo
tengo aquí y vosotros tenéis a y en
vuestra en vuestra y jugar con ella
porque la vida en pocos juego también
darle vueltas cruzar conceptos tiene su
cruzar conceptos estaréis dando con la
clave de que este mundo todo es mezcla y
puesto que todo es mezcla intentemos qué
sea lo más equilibrada posible esa
mezcla y no olvidemos que este mundo es
el camino por el otro que es morada sin
pesar porque vale la pena tener buen
tino para andar esta jornada sin errar
amén
tenemos un minuto
vamos un minuto por delante del tiempo
así que te voy a hacer una pregunta
después de lo que nos has contado
cuál es el sentido de la vida
mira yo tenía la suerte de tener un
padre que tenía una biblioteca muy
curiosa y tenía libros de teología de la
liberación de ética y sociedad de cosas
muy muy interesantes y entonces vi
cíclicas yo leía esas cosas y luego los
comentados con mi padre y tal y eso me
creó un modelo de educación de padres de
relación padre-hijo muy muy muy curiosa
porque yo creo que yo nunca hablado los
hijos el niño siente hablado en serio
siempre ha hablado diciendo las cosas
que sentían que pensaba en ese momento
en tanto uno como a otro y concretamente
mi hija un día me hizo una pregunta muy
crítica porque es la misma crédito ahora
y por eso me acordaba
de papá que es la vida y yo le dije
qué sentido tiene la vida
[Música]
la vida el sentido de la vida es que no
tiene sentido por lo tanto o sea lo
encuentras tú o no tienes nada que hacer
estará [ __ ] a toda la vida hay que
encontrarle sentido a la vida ya eso nos
tenemos que dedicar entonces muchísimas
gracias muchas gracias
[Aplausos]